have you ever heard elon musk
chyna and tom brady in the same story
it's kind of weird ain't it there's a
little bit of weirdness going on there
but let's try to see if we can pull this
off so
elon musk shows the new robot
and then says we definitely need
universal basic income it's eventually
going to happen this is based on the new
tesla bot
during the recent presentation on
artificia on ai hosted by tesla musk
said he is working on creating a tesla
about a robot that would do dangerous
repetitive and boring tasks so humans
don't have to but musk recognized that
the creation of this robot might take
place of the jobs that are people
currently getting paid for which is why
he said a guaranteed income will likely
be necessary in the future essentially
in the future physical work will be a
choice this is why i think long term
there will need to be universal basic
income okay so that's musk and he's
talked about this before this is not the
first time he's talked about this he
talked about this when andrew yanks
started talking about the the the
thousand dollars to everybody the ubi
and it must kind of support it as well
right just to be clear elon musk is a
ubi guy elon musk is a ubi guy and by
the way his argument is a valid argument
because he thinks
technology is going to advance human
beings okay when you're the person
that's creating all this technology you
better be a ubi guy because you're gonna
put millions of people out of work fyi
he also becomes the most dangerous man
in the world if he does that just so you
know because essentially if you create
these robots to be that smart eventually
robots take control of you if you create
them everything he's doing with the
neural link and uh just thinking you
have some theories about that you think
he he wants to you know i think he likes
to bang aliens i think i mean you've
said that maybe once or twice before
maybe more to look at his girl all right
so then let's watch chinese authorities
say
overtime star trek 996 policy is illegal
this is reuters story chinese
authorities say over time 996 policy is
illegal 996 is
you know you're working 99 six days a
week chinese supreme court said overtime
practice of 996 working 996 pm days is
illegal taking aim at the controversial
policy that is common amongst many
chinese technology firms working such
hours has become a badge of honor for
some chinese companies and employees
silicon valley heavyweights such as
sukhoi capitals mike moritz have
highlighted it as a competitive
advantage the country has over united
states chinese tech giants including
tick tock owner bite dance have in
recent months been walking back with
their grueling work hours including the
big week small week policy that requires
workers to alternate five day work weeks
and six day work weeks so that's china
going away from the six stairs right and
sukhoi capital saying they have an edge
over us and then that leads to the brady
story okay so we got musk we got china
we got brady story tom brady disavows
today's work ethic it's not how to live
a joyful life fox news story
brady has some advice on how to be
successful stop blaming everyone else
life is about always changing and
adapting on different things today the
world wants to blame and shame and guilt
and fear everything all the time
we would never teach our kids that you
know we would never say this is how
you're going to get through life the
best you're going to blame everyone when
things don't go right brady called the
sport the ultimate blame game general
managers head coaches players
quarterbacks receivers defense offense
it's so easy to blame someone else it's
so hard to say i didn't get the job done
and we collectively didn't get the job
done that's the best part about team
sports i picked a team where everybody's
like hey we got to get better it's not
like i got all the answers you just
you guys just all screwed it up except
me exact opposite way to play the game
you know you got to play together so
that's what he's saying man he's saying
if you want to make it at that level it
sucks it's not the way to live and don't
blame people so
what are your thoughts about the future
of hard work what's going to happen
phil you want to start this one off oh
my gosh um i mean look
being a bodybuilder
you're your own first responder in
everything you do
i got to get up in the morning
even if i have sheree wake me up i still
gotta move
i still gotta eat that food i still
gotta get on that treadmill this morning
i was like gosh i haven't trained legs
in like a month and i'm gonna go do it i
didn't wanna do it but i try to you know
i live by my own accord i say live life
like leg day
and that means like it's going to hurt
you have fear and anxiety or whatever
but you know what there's a reward and
that reward isn't for everybody else
that reward is for me
so i have a dream of like what i want to
do and i'm like look i'm going to do
this
and here's the best part about being a
bodybuilder that if i eat right i get
results if i train right i get results
practice does not make perfect because i
can practice a lot of freaking bad
habits so i got to be a student of
myself and i have to evolve
throughout my life because what i did in
my 20s i damn sure couldn't do in my 30s
and i'm 41 now and i'm learning a lot
and i'm scratching my head and i'm
thinking
oh my gosh
if i could apply what i know now to the
20 year old phil heath holy smokes but
that's life and it has no rehearsal
whatsoever but
you know what i can't blame a coach
even if i decided you know i work with
hani rambot right
brilliant coach
i lost the olympia in 2018 and in 2020
right
i could literally point at him and say
you know what we didn't do this right
you didn't tell me this who hired him i
did
so you know like the level of
accountability i mean people have to
really start asking themselves are they
holding themselves accountable don't
always look for someone else to do it
man you're making your choices and like
pat said no one's forcing me to compete
either no one's forcing me to do this
podcast no one's forcing me to do [ __ ]
there are two things the two c's i teach
kids and stuff
choices and consequences you've got to
know the damn difference and if you
don't
life is going to teach your ass and it's
going to be a very difficult lesson you
just have to pray to god that it's going
to be a very inexpensive lesson because
if not it's going to be a truly
expensive lesson like we saw at the
beginning of this show
is that those are expensive lessons for
you not understanding your choices
in this life
that's where i'm at with this what do
you think about that adam so you got you
got that great feedback obviously you're
talking about seven times mr olympia and
for bodybuilders uh you're being judged
for every single piece of muscle every
fiber everything that you got going on
right
so
for you
musk says we're going to ubi no matter
what china 996. brady
it's not how to live a joyful life by
blaming everybody take responsibility
who's right
well i think at the end of the day why
do humans work
right obviously the easy answer is like
well i gotta get [ __ ] done but i think
work gives you meaning and purpose to
your life and like i look it's funny
because i'll why i'm sure the people
with pets out there
you know have the same thing you walk
out your door and i see my two cats i'm
like
enjoy your day you two like doing
nothing
right you know you got your dogs all
right just be a dog
so dogs do dog things and cats do cats
things and humans do human things what
do humans do humans need to work work
gives you meaning and purpose and
community and friendship and everything
that that comes associated with work and
improvement like
when you like the picture of you and
when you're in denver playing point
guard or whatever it's a different
fill
imagine if you just
like
obviously with baseball and everything
you did with mma and everything and
everything that imagine if you
pat never put in the work to be where
you are today you were just that 22 year
old still at bally's ah whatever i don't
need to work that hard i think
there was a what was the poll out here
that survey shows that no that people no
longer believe working hard would lead
to a better life
i want to know who actually
took that survey and took that poll
who's raising these freaking kids that's
my biggest question i i can tell you
there are people that i know in the
entertainment industry specifically that
feel that way because they do put in
crazy amounts of hours and they do put
in their all their art and their
intellectual property to being a
comedian they're sleeping on couches and
they're sleeping
capitalism is phenomenal for most things
everybody here knows that i'm a free
market guy capitalism does art pretty
poorly that's one of the things
education and art we don't we don't do
well
with capitalism all right so there are
people in there and they are talented
and they're working very very hard and
they're getting nothing out of it then
they have to do a job now where ubi
comes in is it's it's necessary to
stop
you know revolution ubi is going to
become necessary because if you have
somebody you talked about before
somebody that's a janet or somebody that
maybe tried to make it as a a singer or
something like that got uh got a girl
pregnant got got a guy pregnant got
pregnant by a guy whatever it is and
then necessity had to take over now they
had to take the first job that they
could and they are you know a janitor
they're driving uber they're well i was
when i was shut down in uh non-essential
non-essential tattoo i went from two
national tours i was on two national
tours two years ago to driving uber and
working construction there's only only
two jobs i can get during the pandemic
there was only two essential jobs i
could do i couldn't tell jokes i
couldn't go on tour everybody was gonna
get sick but i could work construction
and i could drive uber
as mad as i was at the world for having
to do that if i didn't have that
available if robots had that job and i
was just sitting there with my credit
evaporating and and my savings
evaporating
i would have gone insane so if you have
people that are taking jobs that they
don't want just to survive and they're
already kind of skeptical about the
system as it is right or they they feel
skeptical about the system and maybe
they are working hard but they're
working hard in low wages where they
don't see any way to move forward
there's only so much money you can make
work as a waitress or a bartender and
it's not like they're not working hard
now if a robot does that which in
australia i'm sure you've traveled the
world patrick's travel the world you
guys have seen this in airports where
now they don't even have bartenders in
some of these places you get a cup and
the cup has a false bottom and you put
it on you put your credit card in and
you put the cup on and it fills the beer
from the bottom it's not even a
bartender you don't you don't tip the
machine so well gee give me give me
so are you a believer in ubi or no dude
honestly i wasn't and i'm coming around
to it because i think it's a necessity
not in this moment andrew yang is early
on so 20 years down the road i think
it's a necessity 20 years down the road
give me give me like we've seen what
happened during cove
two-thirds of people staying home are
getting paid more to stay home than they
were in their job
they're collecting ubi i'm a millionaire
what are people doing with their lives
if you're just getting paid to stay home
what are people doing i don't think that
that's what ubi really is i think ubi is
supposed to be
that basic needs are met and i don't
know the math behind it so well i'm not
necessarily sold on it but i think it's
something that has to be taken seriously
and it's something that needs to be
uh researched as much as possible and i
know that this goes this is a seeming
contradiction to my world view but
again i just think that we're gonna run
into a situation where if you have 10 15
20 30 percent unemployment worldwide you
have a nightmare situation unless you
are going to have a global economy where
there it's going to be cheaper to have
labor and you can go be a construction
worker in africa then you know you can
you can like when i look at uh you know
elon musk and jeff bezos go into space i
don't think about space i think about
international travel in two hours i
think about them going to the upper
atmosphere and then coming back down in
johannesburg and that could be your
morning commute like that's what i think
like if we're gonna have a global
economy uh i i don't know man i think
the world in 50 years is going to be so
different than the world we have today
it's going to be incomprehensible for us
to understand how we didn't function in
those ways pb what was the name of the
guy
that he said i got 10 billion dollars
richer during the pandemic and the
question was does the money flow up does
it flow down yeah what was that story
because i feel like that's where the
money is going to end up with the rich
anyway unfortunately what we can say
everything we want about ubi
people
if you don't change their habits
internally they're going to keep
spending the money money is going to go
to the rich it doesn't matter what you
do you give money to ubi oh we need
universal basic income just think the
money is going to the top billionaires
just think about it that way like it's
going to go through here to the
billionaire so this whole universal
basic income is money to the rich great
go do it it's gonna flow to the rich no
matter what you do now
on the uh com
argument about uh robots taking over all
this other stuff great
so do we know do we not know this whole
thing about robot's been talked about
for a long time
uh education is going to have to change
the approach to school is going to have
to change the approach to what jobs you
go get is going to change uh in a if you
live in bermuda you know what's the
number one job kids go get what degree
they get what is the number one job kids
go get in bermuda can you guess what it
is yeah which one was to do with
hospitality math
because the five reinsurance companies
are in bermuda so when is the last time
you thought about getting a degree in
actuary you don't well in bermuda you do
because you want to go and come back and
work for one of the five actuary
companies so you have to shift the way
you go get a degree if you work in a
place where the biggest employer is ford
and you have to kind of think about hey
i don't want to leave this place i want
to be in detroit great you're going to
go and come back let's just say you're
going to get that job if you're living
in a place where you're in silicon
valley everybody wants to hire a
predictive analytics or an engineer
guess what you're probably going to go
do right if you're living in texas in a
farm place you know raising cattle and
that you're probably going to go do that
it all so we'll pivot we'll adjust
people will be pivoting and adjusting
but money is always going to flow to the
people with the best habits i don't care
what anybody says money is always going
to flow to the people with the best
habits this thing about china's 996
i hate to say this to you but it's kind
of impressive the fact that china is
doing this they're they're 100 years
behind u.s
you know the u.s uh they they did this
with ford because uh back in the days
the average human worker was working 69
hours a week it was 69 hours a week that
we worked the average american worker
used to work
69 hours a week today the numbers around
39 hours a week right give or take right
versus 69 hours now here's the thing
with me
i have worked 996 for nearly 20 years
but it's by choice
i have worked 996 by choice for 20 years
these guys work 996 by fours there's a
big difference i don't know a single
billionaire that you meet
who doesn't have a
you know 8 10 6 for 10 years or 20 years
that is a proven formula if you want to
make it to the high level you got to
really light it up for a good good run
that you go on you got to go on that one
run of yours right so this is mandatory
for everybody that wants to kill it in
their space you need the rest you need
all that stuff but that's that and then
the last part about people no longer
believing
you know working hard will lead to a
better life really okay let's unpack
that people no longer believe let's put
a funnel put a funnel there right what's
the funnel the funnel is a kid is born
the first five years the kids influenced
by who
who's the kid influenced by parents and
then from five years old he goes to
kindergarten he's influenced by who
right friends okay
first to 12 years old they're influenced
by who teachers teachers do teachers
what percentage of teachers love
capitalism
i don't know
then go to college you go to college for
four years you tell me what percentage
of professors in college love capitalism
today tell me how many of them i just
interviewed the communist professor in
riverside community college like the guy
had a great conversation with them he
fully believes the two of the greatest
leaders that help society the most are
stalin and mao he wasn't joking he was
100 firm about it i asked him if a 22
year old kid has a decision today to be
the next jeff bezos created 1.3 million
jobs or be the next stalin what is
better for the world he says it's not
even close stalin if he becomes the next
stalin revolution it's better for the
world this guy fully believes it and
he's not 22 he's 45 years old our age
talking something like that right that
guy's 45
mid 40s no the beard makes him look like
145 but the point is this when people
say things like you know uh surveys show
people no longer believe working hard
will lead to a better life it's not it
should say professors
yeah encourage kids to no longer believe
that working card you got to change the
wording to that title or you could say
you could work smart not hard or maybe
you could do both but the fact that you
just don't want to work hard give me
this bs about
working hard doesn't you gotta you got
to work harder and smarter i mean in
order to be competitive are you kidding
me pat just illustrated it perfectly
when i when i got into bodybuilding
october 8 2002 i said i want to be a
bodybuilder
i recognized that i was at a
disadvantage
because i was going to go against people
that have been doing
lifting weights since they were 12 years
old now i wasn't one of those guys but
yet i did have the genetics right when i
turned pro the gift
when i turned pro 16 years ago it
everything reset
i was a pro i was 25 years old and i'm
going against the best in the world and
i'm thinking
i gotta outwork them i gotta outsmart
them but it's gonna take time
okay
i didn't do the olympia my first two
years of being a pro in 06 and 07 even
though i qualified why because i was
like i need more stage time so i got on
the road i did numerous appearances to
get my stage presence up i knew nothing
about that i had no coach that taught me
those things i did everything in my
power to make sure what i can increase
my capacity at a faster rate than
everybody else so i could equal the
playing field eventually i'm gonna catch
their ass
and guys like dexter you can ask him he
said eventually this kid is gonna win
because i i knew
that i had to do what i couldn't train
just one time a week i had to train
twice a day twice a week but then i was
like well i'm gonna burn out everybody's
like over training this and that well
massage therapist acupuncture infrared
sauna hyperbaric whatever it is instead
of buying [ __ ] i went out and spent
money on those modalities that increased
my capacity so then eventually when i
got there i was i would arrive and then
no wait i did my first olympia got third
the rest is history
i was able to dominate during that time
period because
i'd already made those other years
profitable so then when opportunity met
i was like
let's go but
eight billion people in the world only
four have one mr olympia seven times
okay that's all you're gonna do right
yeah what do you say by the way out work
out work out improve out strategize and
the scariest one at last outlast it's
the most intimidating thing the most
intimidating thing in the world of
competition the fact that you i tell you
i used to tell my competitors
you can beat me one day maybe a week
maybe a month yeah you'll match my work
ethic for a year i will guarantee you
you're going to slow down i'm not
i said you're going to how many years
are you going to go i'm going to go five
years straight i'm going to beat you
i'ma go 10 years you're not gonna last
so that's the mindset that's
intimidating so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you